Narrator: Tonight on
"Shark Tank"...
We created the world's
simplest back pain relief.
Guys, this is extraordinary on
"Shark Tank."
I'm an advanced sleeper.
[ Laughs ]
There we go.
[ Laughter ]
Get a lawyer.
I'm bleeding, people!
We're your
worst nightmare.
Tell us about your
total sales.
We've done
$12 million in sales.
40, 50,000.
$16.
Oh, no.
Your pitch just went downhill
like ‐‐ crash!
Ouch.
John: You're doing those
kind of numbers ‐‐
are you really here
to make a deal?
You guys are grinders,
but I'm afraid for it.
It is the first time in 12 years
I made a royalty deal.
You have learned,
grasshopper.
Slap my mama and
call me "Sally"!
You go, Sally!
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank is a product
to comfort and relieve stress.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks, my name is
Matt Mundt.
And I'm Angie Kupper.
And we are...
Both: Hug Sleep!
[ Chuckles ]
Aww.
We're a husband‐and‐wife team
from Milwaukee, Wisconsin,
and today we are
seeking $150,000
in exchange for
10% of our company.
Sharks, like so
many people out there,
we've got a real problem
in the bedroom.
Hmm?
Between his sleepwalking
and my restless legs,
there's a whole lot of action
and not enough sleep.
So that's why
we invented...
Both: Sleep Pod!
A first‐of‐its‐kind
sleep solution
designed to simulate the feeling
of being hugged or cuddled.
Sleep Pod uses a specialized
4‐way stretch material
that wraps around
your entire body.
Oh, wow.
As its fabric stretches,
it wants to compress,
providing a gentle,
calming pressure,
helping you to relax
and fall asleep.
Now, I know what you're
thinking, and you're right ‐‐
it's essentially
an adult swaddle.
[ Chuckles ]
But Sleep Pod is so much
more than that.
It's made from a breathable
material that doesn't trap heat.
It's lightweight,
so it's easy to travel with.
And best of all,
it's machine‐washable.
And my favorite part
is your significant other...
[ Chuckles ]
...can't steal
your covers.
But in all
seriousness, Sharks,
we spend 1/3
of our life sleeping,
yet so many of us struggle to
get a good night's rest.
With Hug Sleep, we can bring
some magic back into the bedroom
[ Chuckles ]
and get people sleeping
like babies again.
So, Sharks, who want
to jump in bed with us?
So, I know 2020 has been a
little bit of a stressful year,
to say the least, and it looks
like all of you guys
could really use
a good hug right now.
We'd ask Robert and we'd love
to have you come up here
and test out
Sleep Hug.
To hug you?
No, no, no!
To try Sleep Hug!
Oh!
There you go!
Unless you really
want a hug.
Alright, go ahead and have
a seat on the side of the bed.
You're gonna put it on just
like you would a pair of pants.
So put both legs.
Both?
Both legs. Yep.
And you're gonna
stay seated for this...
Okay.
...but go ahead
and scooch back
and swing your legs
over onto the bed.
Go ahead
and get comfortable.
You wanna pull
it up to your chest.
You may wanna
go back on the ‐‐ Yeah.
Oh. Pull it.
Yeah, you can
scooch your butt back.
Cuban: Just stand up. Pull it.
Now, Robert,
start hopping.
So it fits
pretty snug?
It is.
Yes.
We don't advise
to do that.
Yes, 'cause we don't
want you to fall.
Oh, it feels great!
And now,
put your arms
your arms in it, right?
Put my arms in?
So you actually want to lay down
before you do that,
'cause I would hate
to see you fall.
I'm an advanced
sleeper.
[ Laughs ]
There you go.
So now, yeah,
you can lay down.
Greiner: Wow.
[ Laughter ]
It's actually really
soothing.
Why is there
a pocket?
Kupper: Yeah. So we're going
to tell you about that.
That's the
newest addition.
A lot of people
like to sleep
with one foot out
for temperature regulation.
Mm‐hmm.
Ohhh.
So that is a pocket
so you can, if you want.
But if you choose
not to ‐‐
Oh, see?
[ Laughter ]
You okay, Robert?
[ Whimpering ] I'm okay.
That definitely doesn't
normally happen.
Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
See what we have
to deal with?
Oh, my God!
I'm bleeding!
[ Sighs ] Hey.
Greiner: [ Laughing ]
Oh, my God!
Cuban: Robert
is bleeding.
Robert, are you okay?
I hate you!
[ Chuckles ]
Kupper: Oh, no!
[ Laughing ] Oh.
You're doing everything
we advise against, so...
Okay, let's talk
about acceptance in the market.
Robert, are we gonna
talk about that?
Robert is sitting
here bleeding.
[ Chuckling ]
Are we gonna talk about that?
I'm bleeding, people!
Get a lawyer.
[ Chuckles ]
Before I bled to death...
Yeah.
...it was very comfortable.
Good. Good.
Okay, so, guys ‐‐ sales.
So it's been about 16 months
or so since we started selling.
Lifetime sales to
date are about 490,000.
So in the last 12 months or so,
we've done 335,000
in top line sales.
On that, we grossed
about 215,
and our net on
that is about 140.
Greiner:
Where were you selling?
Yeah, so we sell
direct to consumer
through our website,
as well as Amazon.
And what do you sell them
for online,
and what does it cost you
to make landed?
It typically
sells for $99.99.
And each Sleep Pod costs us on
average about $22.50 to make.
But as we continue
to scale,
we can get that down
to about 18 bucks.
So I just put it on. It's warm,
it's very silky‐soft feeling.
Mm‐hmm.
Very snuggly.
Very stretchy.
Absolutely.
So I think it'll be really
helpful if we took a step back
and kind of explain
how this came to be.
So a few years ago,
I heard about weighted blankets,
like the rest of
the world.
I ended up buying
one of these weighted blankets,
and I tried it on,
and I loved it.
That initial pressure really
brought on this sense of calm.
But I went to sleep later
that night, and very quickly,
I ran into the all‐too‐common
list of complaints
associated with
weighted blankets.
1, they trap heat like crazy
and they just overheat.
Next, they're very
difficult to wash.
You can't just take
a 30‐pound weighted blanket
and throw it
in your washing machine.
Washing machine would
probably explode, right?
I'm a mechanical engineer
who's been able to work
at some pretty
cool companies,
so I'm no stranger to creating
solutions to problems.
Like, okay, maybe you don't use
weight to create pressure,
but you use compression.
And this way, it wraps
around your entire body
and really, truly stimulates
a feeling of being hugged.
And, Angie,
what's your background?
So I'm a therapist.
I have a master's degree
in community psychology.
I specialize in the treatment
of anxiety disorders
for kids and adolescents.
So I knew,
more than a lot of people,
how important sleep is ‐‐
not just for our
physical health,
but our mental health, too,
so when he told me this idea,
I was already aware of
deep touch pressure therapy,
not only for things like
autism, which is what it
was originally designed for,
but for anxiety disorders,
for post‐traumatic stress
disorders.
Deep touch pressure therapy
is basically gentle
but firm pressure
applied to the body
Okay, the question is here ‐‐
how much time and energy
do you have to spend explaining
the merits of the product
to acquire the customer?
So our cost of acquisition
has been phenomenal.
What is it?
$11.50 blended.
Wow.
And that's over
the last six months.
Very good.
And this is scalable.
Primarily on Facebook?
Yeah.
So we're running PPC campaigns
on Facebook and Instagram.
What'd you do last month?
What did you do last month?
So last month was
our highest revenue month ever.
We did 50,000
last month.
And were you profitable?
Oh, absolutely.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, so how much
did you make in profits?
So our net profit is usually
about 41% of our top line sales,
so it was
about 22,000.
Good for you.
That's awesome.
Congrats.
Yeah. Thank you.
You're killing it.
And we did bootstrap
this company
with $2,500.
Yeah, baby!
That's all you've put in?
That is all we put in,
and we were profitable
within the first
week or two of selling.
I hope everybody at home
is hearing that.
Alright. What are you gonna
use the 150,000 for?
So demand has been crazy,
and we really need inventory.
I get it.
So ‐‐ I like it.
I want to offer you
$150,000 for 20%.
Well, thank you
for that offer.
Yes, thank you.
Would you like to say yes?
So I don't want to
drop valuation that much.
You can counter.
What's your
counter, Matt?
O'Leary: I'm intrigued also
because of one thing.
John: Kevin, why don't you
let him answer?
He was about to
say something.
It may make it
better for you!
Maybe my offer will just make
Daymond's evaporate.
That's why you don't have to
worry about countering.
Well, maybe we could just make
you evaporate.
[ Chuckles ]
No, I'd just look
at it and say
that you know your
customer acquisition cost.
Mundt: Mm‐hmm.
I would just like to pour more
money onto that very model.
The value I would add here
is to drive
that acquisition cost down.
I'll do the deal at 15%.
Well, thank you.
Thank you for the offer.
Thank you.
Are you gonna accept it?
Wait a minute.
I'm gonna give you an offer.
Whoa.
My offer would be
$150,000 also for the 15%.
Thank you.
Well, and I guess there's
something I want to make
sure I put out there.
There are a lot of
people suffering from
anxiety, sleeplessness.
We're not getting
a lot of hugs.
[ Chuckles ]
And so this really is something
that hugs you back,
even if you are alone.
I personally really benefit
from the Sleep Pod.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Sniffles ]
[ Voice breaking ]
Because one of my best
memories from childhood
was being tucked in
by my mom every night.
[ Exhales sharply ]
The reason I went
into psychology
is I lost my mom
to suicide when I was 17.
And through all
of that pain,
I found a passion
for helping other people.
It can help so many people.
I love helping kids.
I'm dedicated to
helping kids,
but there are adults out there
who need help, too.
And this product can fit so many
people and so many needs.
And so I want to make sure that
we make a deal with somebody
who's just as passionate
about this as we are.
You know, I love it, guys.
And I've got people in my
household and my family
that have sensory issues,
so that's why
it's very close to me.
And so I'll make you
an offer.
I'll give you a choice.
I'm gonna give you two offers.
One will be just
what you asked for ‐‐
$150,000 for 10%.
And the one I'd prefer is
$300,000 for 20%.
So that way, we're
closer partners.
That, I think we could
really run with it.
I'll give you the same offer
and the same choices.
Wait a minute.
I'll match the same offer.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
and a bidding war is underway
for Angie and Matthew's
therapeutic swaddle
for adults, Hug Sleep.
So, guys, you're going to get
five offers.
I don't know
how often that happens.
Not often.
No.
And look, there's only one
person up here
who actually bled
for you guys.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughs ]
I appreciate that.
Alright, here's
my offer ‐‐
$300,000 for 20%.
That's my offer.
Guys, this is extraordinary
on "Shark Tank."
It is.
What do you guys want to do?
[ Both exhale sharply ]
[ Shakily ] I don't
even know.
[ Chuckles ]
Well, I think we certainly
understand the value
that all you Sharks bring, and,
you know, if any of you guys
would be willing
to kind of come together,
I think that's
just going to continue
Lori.
to explode this company.
Alright, Lori and I
will do it together.
The 300 for 20.
Well, I think
if you guys are teaming up
and kicking us
to the curb...
Kevin, Daymond,
will you come in?
'Cause I think three Sharks
is better than two.
O'Leary: Ooh,
that's interesting.
John: I think so.
Alright. I'll come in
with Kevin and Robert.
Oh, God.
Three Sharks versus two.
That's interesting.
Herjavec: Three Sharks,
$300,000 for 20%.
O'Leary: Yeah, that's
a tough one.
Oh, my God.
Three's better than two.
♪♪
This is a good
problem to have.
A very good
[ Whispering ]
What do you want to do?
I know we came in initially
targeting Mark and Lori.
You guys want to do a deal
at 20% for 300,
you got yourself
a deal.
Done.
Thank you!
And I can't move,
but ‐‐ [ Laughs ]
Herjavec: Damn it!
I'm suing you
for making me bleed!
I'm not going to sleep
at night now.
Congratulations, guys.
Thank you.
Together:
Congratulations, guys.
[ Chuckles ]
That was pretty
incredible.
We did it.
[ Sniffles ]
[ Exhales sharply ]
Phew!
2020's been
a scary time,
and I think Sleep Pod's
gonna help a lot of people.
The little bit that we can do
to just help people to feel safe
and secure and less anxious.
And I'm so proud of you.
[ Chuckles ] I'm proud of you.
That was incredible.
Oh, man.
♪♪
Narrator:
In season 11, Natalie Holloway
and Max Kislevitz
made a deal with
Maria Sharapova and Mark Cuban
for their innovative wrist
and ankle weights, Bala Bangles.
You've got a deal.
Yes!
Narrator: Let's check in
with them now.
Holloway: We aired on
"Shark Tank" just two weeks
before the world shut down
due to the global pandemic.
Kislevitz:
With people trying to figure out
ways to work out at home,
we sold out immediately.
Now, in just five months,
we've done $7.5 million.
And we'll hit $15 million
by year's end.
The last few months
have been challenging,
but having Mark
and Maria as partners
have been very valuable
during this time.
You came in with this
old‐school workout routine,
and I was like, "Wow,
this is so off the grid."
Yeah. [ Chuckles ]
Sharapova:
When Max and Natalie first
presented Bala Bangles,
I really believed in them
and thought that they could do
so much to the brand,
and they really have.
I love the
new packaging.
One of Maria's
first notes
was to make our packaging
more retail‐friendly.
The fact that the customers
can really see
what's inside the package
is a huge benefit to them.
Cuban: Being able to expand into
multiple products,
your growth has been
through the roof.
Mark encouraged us to develop
a line of new products.
The Bala Bars are our take
on dumbbells.
The Power Ring is our take
on the kettlebell.
Now, with a full line
of products,
we have landed huge accounts,
like Saks Fifth Avenue,
Anthropologie,
and Dillard's.
Our biggest news is securing
Dick's Sporting Goods,
with 640 locations.
I can't wait to see
what comes next.
The future has a lot of great
potential for you guys.
Our advice to entrepreneurs
is just to start.
Kislevitz:
Take steps even if you don't
know where you're going.
Sharapova: I was an athlete
for 28 years.
I tried so many products
and visited so many gyms.
This is so much more
than fitness.
This is about a lifestyle.
And I'm so excited
to be part of this process.
"Shark Tank" has meant
everything for our business.
It's been
absolutely insane.
And it's only the
beginning for Bala.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up are
entrepreneurs who are hoping
to hook the Sharks
with their unique idea.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Kanz!
And I'm Sobhan.
And we're seeking
$325,000
in exchange for 10%
of our revolutionary company.
Sharks,
we love fishing!
[ Chuckling ] Oh, yes, we do.
We love fishing so much.
But we experience
a lot of frustration
with the old, traditional
fishing methods.
See, sometimes people
spend more time and energy
fidgeting with
traditional lures
and catching live bait
than they do actually fishing.
Not to mention, who wants
to deal with this...
gross mess?
Ewwww!
We looked at the
nasty baits
and lures available in stores
today but couldn't find
anything that attracted fish
in a simple and efficient way,
so we created it
ourselves.
Introducing
Animated Lure.
Animated Lure is a
rechargeable robotic lure,
the likes of which
the world has never seen.
Once you place Animated Lure
into the water,
you'll notice it starts
to swim on its very own,
mimicking the swim patterns
of real fish.
Oh, wow!
Wow.
If you think it swims
like a real fish,
what are the fish
going to think?
So, why?
[ Chuckling ] Why?
Why spend so much time
and money on traditional lures
and live bait, when
you can use...
Both: Animated Lure?
See how much you can learn
on "Shark Tank?" It's amazing.
Herjavec:
It's amazing, Kevin!
John: Amazing!
Greiner: You know,
I have to ask
Daymond, though ‐‐
O'Leary: Who knew?
Is this different than anything
you've ever used to fish with?
John:
Yeah, I've never seen it.
How often does it rust?
Or, you know,
like, how many times
do you need to
re‐buy that unit?
Sanaee: Yeah, yeah.
So, right now we have
about 40 times.
This is with action,
with you catching fish
and stuff like that.
So how long does it
hold a charge for?
So, for different sizes.
For the minis,
up to 45 minutes of swim.
For the classic is
an hour and a half.
For the biggest one you see,
the Salt Water,
the one that's in
production right now,
that's up to
two hours.
What makes you guys
fish experts?
Why should I believe you?
I'm a project manager at
manufacturing facilities and...
And I'm actually a licensed
professional counselor.
I'm working in community mental
health in Collin County.
Well, then,
it makes sense.
[ Chuckles ]
No, no, but it's something
that we saw growing up.
And if I may, my dad and I
used to go fishing all the time,
and I don't share
about my dad too often,
so please bear with me.
Him and I used to go fishing
all the time,
all the way until he was
diagnosed with a lung disease
and concluded
his human experience.
But it was during those times
where we noticed
some of the problems
that exist
with the old, traditional
fishing method.
And so
they have always taught us
to not only
identify problems,
but to try your best
to be part of the solution.
And so these words
meant a lot to me
because it came
from two individuals
that sacrificed everything
to come to this country
so that their children have
an opportunity
to contribute to
the betterment of society.
Also, to take control
of their own destiny.
Where did you come from?
Iran. Iran.
From Persia. Yeah.
Iran.
What do these cost you to make?
What do you sell them for?
And tell us about
your total sales.
Perfect. The landing price
for the Mini is $8.
For the classic,
it's $10.
And what does the
new big one cost?
$16.
For the Mini,
it's retailing at $29.95.
For a Classic,
$32.95.
And for our Salt Water,
it's $79.95.
Greiner: Wow!
Is it all direct or
are you through retail?
There's a huge
margin on the Salt.
Right now, it's majority
on our website.
However, we are
in a few mom‐and‐pop stores
here in the United States.
We also have
a distributor in Canada.
We're in about
40 stores there.
What about the big boys?
Bass and all the rest?
That's where we're hoping to
make a deal, and we don't know.
Ohhh!
They'll pick up
your phone calls, for sure.
Okay, but while we're still
talking dollars...
Sure.
Yes.
...and costs.
$325,000, 10% imputes
a $3.25 million value.
You must be selling
a lot of mechanical fish.
2020 to date,
we're at $247,000.
Good for you.
We're projecting
for this year
half a million dollars in sales,
and then, even next year,
$675,000 in sales.
You guys are
making money right now?
So, yes. So right now, me and
Sobhan both work full‐time jobs.
We have zero debt
in this company.
Good.
We've put everything, our own
money, into this company.
How much did you put in?
$125,000 to get
the ball rolling
so we could
get this done.
You didn't mess around,
did you?
No, no, no, we haven't taken a
penny out of our own company.
Yeah.
Every cent we've earned,
we put back into our company.
John: Do you own the company?
Herjavec:
As you should.
Yes. Equally.
Yes, sir.
I'm thinking the way to sell
this is, forget about fishing.
Put 10 of them in a tank
and call it an aquarium.
You don't have to feed it.
Cuban: Yeah. You know what?
At, like, a restaurant or
something like that.
[ Laughter ]
That is
a good idea!
Greiner:
And it never dies!
That's a great idea.
Cuban: Hey, guys, look,
it really is a good idea.
It really is clever.
But I'm just not a fisherman.
I just don't have
that feel for it.
And so, while I'm proud
of what you've accomplished...
Appreciate you.
...I have to say
I'm out.
That's fine.
No worries. Thank you.
Listen, I am not
a fisherman, either.
I just know a little bit.
And for those reasons,
'cause I don't know,
It's a little too early
for me.
I'm out.
Guys, you're not
really a company.
You're basically
a product right now
because both of you
have real jobs.
And that's nothing
wrong with that.
How do I get my $325,000
back again?
The reality of the situation is,
it's not about what you know ‐‐
it's about who you know,
and we know that you know
that you guys know
a lot of people.
But think about what
you're saying.
I give you $325,000,
then I go to work for you,
opening up big box retail.
I get on the phone,
I fly to meet the buyer
or whatever I have to do,
and I'm working so you,
who have 90% of the company,
can say, "Good dog. Good dog."
And I gave you all the money.
Either I'm going to get a
huge percentage of this company
'cause it's not even worth
$325,000 yet,
or you're gonna come up
with some very creative way
that I get my capital back while
my partners own 90%.
You know,
that's the problem.
That's a royalty deal
he's looking for.
Did you say
"royalty deal," Lori?
Oh. Hark.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my goodness.
So, here's what I suggest ‐‐
I give you the 325,000,
I get $3 a unit until
I recoup a million bucks.
10% of the company in case
somebody decides to buy it.
That is a
great offer.
Of course it is.
Let me just tell you
where I stand.
There's something you said
that really bothered me.
You said, "It's not
what you know.
It's who you know."
When I started out,
everyone said that to me.
"You're never going to make it.
You don't know anybody."
I was screwed before I started
if I believed that.
It's not who you know.
It's what you make
with what you have.
That's fair.
I respect
the dream
and I really respect
the hustle you guys have...
I appreciate it.
...but this isn't
a business for me.
I think you've got
a long way to go. I'm out.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
John: Alright. The product ‐‐
superb, amazing.
Where I'm struggling is,
of course, the valuation.
If I gave you
325 for 10%,
basically,
as you drill down the numbers,
paying yourself and, you know ‐‐
on a 40%, even 50% margin,
you would have to do
almost $35 million
to then take distribution
for me to make my money.
You came here to fish
for a Shark,
but you didn't hook
this one.
I'm out.
Yeah.
Well, then...
all roads lead back
to Mr. Wonderful...
and the fish.
What are you
gonna do?
So, our counter would be
20% for half a million dollars.
Cuban: Hello!
Okay, hold on.
And how many dollars
a unit in royalty?
So in this counter,
no royalty.
[ Laughter ]
Ohh! Don't you know
who he is?
I thought we were on
the planet Earth together.
Let me absorb the counter
so I can just
get the essence of it.
[ French accent ]
The essence.
[ Normal voice ] Instead of me
giving you 325 for 10%,
I give you half a million
for 20%,
and I may never see it again.
It may swim away 'cause we don't
know what's gonna happen.
We want some guidance.
We're young.
We're still learning
the ropes.
The first guidance is ‐‐
listen when you have
a real investor on the hook
and don't come back
with a stupid counter.
I have a question.
Do you want him?
That's
a ridiculous counter.
Look, look,
I can't take it.
Are we doing a royalty deal
or not here? Yes or no?
Yes, we'll talk
about that. Yes.
Can we ‐‐
Can we talk about it?
Can you put
the hat?
Alright.
♪♪
Okay. So, what we can do
is that 10% mark, but $1.50,
and then we can do it
to $500,000.
No, no. That's not attractive,
guys, 'cause I'm ‐‐
I'm getting the feeling
there's not a meeting
of the minds here, guys.
What are you doing?
Guys ‐‐ Guys, I'm sorry.
If you can give us
a final counter ‐‐
We're not gonna get there.
Cuban: Say it!
I'm out.
Oh, guys! You had
the big fish on the hook!
All you had to do
was reel it in.
O'Leary:
You priced it too high ‐‐
way too high.
That's the mistake.
Everybody learns
from a mistake like this
because it is
a unique product.
Everybody understands
the merit of it.
But I am not gonna give you
$325,000
unless you agree to my terms
right now.
Last chance for romance.
What do you want to do?
♪♪
Kevin,
you got a deal.
Yeah!
Whoa!
How'd you revive
that one?
Greiner: What?!
That's how you do it.
Guys, thank you,
thank you, thank you.
That fish was dead!
Congratulations, guys.
Kanz: Thank you.
Congrats.
Wow, what a shocker!
♪♪
Whoo!
Let's go!
Let's go, baby!
We got that!
Sanaee: Even though
Kevin made a sharky deal,
we know what
he's able to bring.
We just started out as two
little kids who loved fishing.
For us to make it this far
and achieve the American dream,
that's wonderful
for us.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up are entrepreneurs
with a product
they believe is to die for.
Ooooh!
Uh‐oh. Scary.
[ Eerie music plays ]
Oh, I get it.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
We're your worst nightmares.
We're cereal killers.
[serial]
[ Laughter ]
And I'm invading
your sweet cereal dreams.
And I'm stalking your morning
cereal bowl.
Just kidding!
Hi!
I'm Cereal Killer Jess.
And I'm Cereal Killer
Chris.
We're here from
North Las Vegas, Nevada,
seeking $125,000
for 10% of our company...
Both:
The Cereal Killerz Kitchen!
We are the first...
And only...
cereal bar
in Las Vegas.
Wait,
what's a cereal bar?
It's a place where your
childhood dreams can come true.
Think back.
It's Saturday morning.
Your favorite cartoons are on,
and you rush to the kitchen
to prepare the perfect
handcrafted bowl of cereal.
Mmm!
Just when you thought Saturdays
couldn't get any better,
in comes the
Cereal Killerz Kitchen,
where every day is Saturday.
At the Cereal Killerz Kitchen,
the opportunities are endless!
You can mix
over 140 different cereals,
50 toppings into
cereal bowls, waffles,
iced coffees, ice cream,
and milkshakes.
You name it!
Your cereal dreams can come true
with any combination!
Sharks,
now's your time to kill it
and join us
on our crazy quest
to take over the cereal world
one bowl at a time.
What do we have?
We have three different things.
So you have
our signature shake.
So this one is, like,
our most popular.
So pretty much, it's hazelnut,
Nutella, chocolate, caramel.
What is in this?!
Okay, so...
you will love that one.
This one ‐‐
You're gonna love the Survivor.
So, we heard
that you love peanut butter
and that you have it
every morning...
Love peanut butter.
...so we gave you
a peanut butter lover's dream.
In your particular ice cream,
it does have chocolate,
and then we added a scoop
of peanut butter ‐‐
That is crazy!
This is amazing!
Really, really,
really good.
Okay, how many calories
in that peanut butter thing?
Uh, probably between
500 and 5,000.
[ Laughter ]
I really
can't tell you.
This is like milkshakes,
like sundaes,
like, this is ‐‐
you're combining everything.
Oh, this is so good!
Ice cream ‐‐ Yeah,
we do pretty much
just
a big difference ‐‐
Pretty much ‐‐
cereal bar,
but we can do
so many different things.
O'Leary: I want to know
what we're investing in.
Is it a retail location?
What are you doing here?
Okay.
We have one open already.
We're opening
our second location.
Herjavec: So you have
one physical location.
You just opened
another one.
Yeah, we're opening
And then, we're pretty much
in negotiations
for our next three.
I mean, you know the question
everyone's gonna ask.
Yeah.
Are you even open
right now?
Yes. So we've been back open
for about a month and a half now
'cause we were shut down
for three months.
Our first location
is in a dreaded mall.
So the malls
were completely shut down.
No one can go in
or out.
Is that location
even gonna survive?
Honestly,
probably not.
But we already have
a contingency plan for that.
What's the plan?
We're opening up another store
right across the street.
[ Laughter ]
How are you guys gonna afford
all this?
Just leftover money
that we have.
'Cause with our plan, you know,
it's taking about $25,000
to remodel these stores.
How much cash
do you have left?
Uh, personally, probably
about $40,000, $50,000.
How did you come up
with this idea?
I've always loved cereal.
We do have a daughter
that does have a mild case
of Down syndrome.
And she's a chef
in her head,
so she's always like, "What do
you guys want for breakfast?"
And she's always like,
"Cinnamon Toast Crunch."
So that's ‐‐ I was like,
you know what?
I've always thought it should
have been a cereal bar,
so we started doing
the research,
and we're just like,
"Hey, let's try to do it."
So what's your background,
though? Tell us about you.
So I was in insurance
for about 12 years.
It wasn't something
that made me happy.
I didn't love it.
I was going to quit.
The next thing you know,
I get fired 2 weeks
before our wedding.
Oh, no.
What happened?
Honestly,
my performance wasn't there.
It was like I could not
commit to something
I hated doing
every day anymore.
One of the first times
I ever heard somebody take
responsibility for being fired.
Greiner:
I like your honesty.
I respect that.
And for me,
I grew up in Vegas,
lived in Richmond, California,
for a little while.
When we lived
in Richmond,
you know, things were probably
worse as you can get.
We were homeless,
lived in plenty
of homeless shelters,
rescue missions,
couch‐surfed, family to family.
But I probably went to
9 different middle schools.
I couldn't read.
But now something clicked.
I read.
Went to college.
Got on the dean's List ‐‐
3.7.
So it was like, hey, you know,
we need to get this up
so we can take care
of our family.
And especially having a daughter
with Down syndrome.
You know,
it is my stepdaughter,
but that's, like,
my pride and joy.
Like, that's really
what made me become a man.
This is not
a proprietary concept.
I mean, it's a great idea.
I get it.
But others could do it,
obviously.
I have a feeling
that none of these locations
that you have so far
make money yet, right?
Well, the second one's not open
'cause we pushed it off.
Well, there is no location
right now.
The one in the mall
is still open.
In the mall.
Yeah, it's still open.
And how much is that
losing a month?
Probably right now,
about $8,000 a month.
Ouch!
Herjavec: Losing.
Yeah, in that one.
I want to just say to you ‐‐
your story ‐‐ very moving
because you have just come
from remarkable odds.
If I were betting
on entrepreneurs,
I would bet on you 100%.
Thank you, Lori.
I have one conflict here.
I did a deal with
an oatmeal breakfast bar place,
and so, unfortunately,
I try not to do something
that is a conflict
with something
that we are trying
to build.
Are trying to build.
I understand.
And so only for that reason,
I have to be out.
Okay.
♪♪
I think what you're trying
to do is extremely difficult.
You're trying to open retail
and create a brand
and pull people in.
That is an uphill battle.
If anybody's gonna do it,
it's probably gonna be
you guys.
Yeah,
it definitely is.
But I'm not sure
I have the stomach
for that kind of investment.
I'm out.
♪♪
You're very, very,
very early.
I mean,
the product tastes great.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
But until you have a profitable
location, you're not investable.
Okay.
Understandable.
You've got to prove it
with one place,
and you haven't
done that yet.
I'm sorry, guys.
It's not for me right now.
I'm out.
Okay.
♪♪
You know, here's my thought ‐‐
you know, I'm...
I'm getting emotionally tied
into the deal because ‐‐
Everybody loves it.
'cause of things you said.
This has been
in my family's life
for probably 25,
30 years.
So we couldn't find anything
good for you, but ‐‐
That's my ma‐‐
I knew I liked that guy!
FUBU! He's not a quitter,
that's for damn sure.
Hold on.
You know, this is a 3X.
You know, we used to wear
big 3Xs back then.
After COVID, I'll be wearing 3X.
Don't worry.
How you gonna say no?
You can't be out.
[ Laughs ]
[ Chuckles ]
Cuban:
Come on, Daymond.
Everybody loves cereal.
Who doesn't love cereal?
That's
the easiest market.
The problem isn't cereal.
Look, in my house,
when Daddy has to cook,
It's always cereal, right?
That's just the way it works.
But I'm afraid for you,
right?
I'm just gonna be
brutally honest.
You guys are grinders,
and now you're looking
at opening up more stores
because you have the sense that
when you get more stores open,
you'll get more revenue
and your costs will go down
and somehow it'll work out.
It doesn't work that way,
though.
Now you've got this other
40 or $50,000
that you've got saved up,
which is your whole life ‐‐
everything.
And you're saying,
"I'm all‐in,"
which sounds really good
to show you're committed.
But when you said, you know,
"I'm figuring it out" ‐‐
you can't do it that way.
You're burning that money
because if you can't
get one right,
it's impossible to do
two, three, or four.
Yes, sir.
You're not ready
to take investment.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
But please,
before you open up any stores,
get somebody to work for you,
with you, partner with you
that is an expert in accounting,
that has legal background,
that can get you
through these steps,
'cause that 40 to $50,000
for your kids,
for your future
is everything.
Yes, sir.
♪♪
John: My biggest challenge
with you is that
you do look spread
a little thin, you know?
Listen,
it's a long road ahead, right?
I do believe your business will
hopefully get better in Vegas.
It's actually
a great company for you,
but I don't think
it's investable
or beneficial for an investor,
so I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
♪♪
It's alright.
Thank you.
Thank you
for everything.
We really appreciate it,
guys.
‐Good luck.
‐Good luck, guys.
I'll be stopping in.
We gave it our best.
We did good.
We tried.
We're gonna be the biggest
cereal company in the world.
One bowl at a time.
[ Laughs ]
I'm a little disappointed
that we didn't make a deal,
but still positive.
I still think that with
the feedback they gave us
and with our tenacity,
we're just going to keep pushing
forward, keep moving forward,
and try our best to just survive
in these current times.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a product
to alleviate
common aches and pains.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Tate Stock.
My business is Chirp,
and we're here about
a very serious matter ‐‐
back pain.
It's the worst.
We created the world's
simplest back pain relief ‐‐
the Chirp Wheel.
And we'd love to show you
how it works.
But first,
let's go over all of this.
[ Laughs ]
These bubbles represent
those hard‐to‐reach muscle knots
in your back
and your neck.
Now, most people use
a foam roller
to roll out their backs.
As he rolls out,
there should be enough pressure
to make the bubbles pop,
symbolizing that deep tissue ‐‐
ahhh ‐‐ back pain relief.
[ Crinkling ]
What's that ‐‐
one pop?
Even though it touches
his entire back,
there's just not enough contact
to be effective.
So let's try it again
with the Chirp Wheel.
♪♪
[ Popping ]
Wow.
Slap my mama and call me Sally.
That's a lot of pops!
[ Laughter ]
The Chirp Wheel
is designed
to fit perfectly
between your shoulder blades.
The compression‐sensitive
padding
and our patent pending
spinal canal
relieve pressure
off the spine
and stretch the muscles
around it in 4 directions
for the deepest
possible stretch.
Now, the Chirp Wheel
comes in 3 sizes,
each applying
different amounts of pressure.
Now, with over
a million wheels sold,
I'm here today
seeking $900,000
for 2% of Chirp.
Ohhhh! 900...
[ Laughter ]
That is definitely
chirping.
You go, Sally!
Come on, Robert. You know
you want to come try it.
Alright.
I got to try it.
So, let's have you grab
your 10‐inch wheel.
Yeah,
just the medium one.
Alright.
This is your mat here.
And we're gonna sit
all the way down on the ground.
Let me take that off.
I can't do it with that.
Alright. Square it up,
and then just lean back.
You can keep your arms
on the ground.
There you go. Yep.
Oh, wow.
And if you roll all the way
down to your hips,
just open up your hips,
and you can just sit there.
Let it open up your hips,
open up your chest.
Oh, wow.
That really works!
Yeah, you probably
get some ‐‐
Holy smokes!
It's amazing
how well it works.
What did it feel like?
It's way better
than you think.
It was super easy.
It was really good.
O'Leary: Okay, Tate.
So I'm going to give you
that special moment
to explain why this is worth
$45 million.
So, this year so far,
we've done $12 million in sales.
What?!
12 million?
Correct.
12?
Correct. $12 million sales
this year. $4 million profit.
By the end of this year,
we expect to do
$40 million in sales
with $12 million
in profit.
So what is it
that you need from a Shark?
That's a great question.
The wheel is simple,
and it's effective.
We've sold over a million
of them.
I have 5 people
in front of me
that are the greatest investors
in America,
and you guys are sitting
on things that I don't know.
I read over 60 books a year,
but I'm 28 years old,
and I want to have the mind‐set
of a 45‐year‐old entrepreneur.
[ Chuckles ]
Well, I'm not buying
any of that...
That's the worst.
...because if there's
one thing you know,
you know how to sell
$12 million of a round wheel.
Yeah, your pitch
just went downhill,
like, crash, Tate,
after that comment.
A 45‐year‐old
entrepreneur knows
not to offer 2% to anybody,
so...
So, also with our hyper growth,
we need funding for P. O. s.
But you said you just had
$4 million
in cash this year, right?
Greiner: But you're
making money.
You have $4 million
in profit.
We are making money,
but our P. O. that's in right now
is for $4 million,
and so ‐‐
From who? Who are you getting
theses P. O. s from?
All B2C. So we mainly sell
through our website.
How do you market them
to get to your website?
Mainly through
social channels ‐‐
Instagram and Facebook.
Our cost to acquire a customer
is about $20 to $30.
That's high.
Herjavec: So what did
you spend on marketing
last year ‐‐ this year?
We've spent about
$3 million.
So, when COVID hit
in March,
we had 3 months of inventory,
and we ran out in 3 weeks.
When we've sold out ‐‐
we've actually been missing out
on about $4 million
a month in sales.
What's the price
for a 3‐pack?
3‐pack is 99 bucks.
Our cost ‐‐
What's your cost?
COGs on it landed are $21.96
for the 3‐pack.
It's about $6, $8,
and $10 for individual.
Comes from China?
They're manufactured
in Taiwan.
Do you have any debt?
No.
Do you have any partners?
No partners.
You don't have any debt,
zero partners,
and you're doing
those kind of numbers.
Are you really here
to make a deal?
Honestly,
I am here to make a deal.
So why the 2%?
Why come in at all?
You do realize a lot of people
right now don't have jobs.
They don't have
a career.
Correct.
You know, a lot of people
will close their businesses,
and they'll never come back.
Why take the carpet from
somebody who needs the money?
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but Daymond questions Tate's
motives for coming to the Tank
with his back wheel business,
Chirp,
when he might not need
the investment.
Why take the carpet from
somebody who needs the money?
We believe
that the Chirp wheel
needs to be
in every home in America.
So do not care
about anybody else
who desperately
needs the money.
He's trying
to grow his business.
I'm asking the man
a question.
Well, if he grows big enough,
he can hire more people,
so there you go.
I am genuine on this carpet
about looking for a deal.
I want to have a creative offer
for you guys
where you guys
make your money back fast.
If we do over $100 million
in sales next year,
I would love to cut you a check
for the million dollars,
what you invested back
into the company.
So if I gave you an offer
right now
for $900,000 for 2%,
you're telling me
that you would give it back
to me at the end of the year?
The end of next year.
So, I will give you that offer
if you will do that.
You want creativity,
here it comes.
I like sales.
You've got sales, alright?
I can get you 15% less on
your customer acquisition costs.
Whatever you're doing,
my team can do it better.
That's what I believe,
alright?
[ Laughter ]
Love it.
I'll give you the $900,000
for 2.5% equity,
and I want a royalty
of $3 a unit
till I get back
$2.7 million.
So I'm basically
doubling my dough,
[ Laughs ]
and I don't have
a time limit.
I'm not putting you
under pressure on time
'cause poo‐poo
happens in businesses,
and I don't know
what's gonna happen to you.
But remember one thing ‐‐
there's only one Mr. Wonderful.
Thank God for that.
♪♪
I'm really here to give
opportunity to people
that may be
at an earlier stage than you
or maybe not had
as much success as you.
I'm not holding your success
against you at all.
I'm just saying to you
it doesn't feel right for me
at the moment.
With that, I'm out.
Thank you.
I appreciate the feedback.
Tate, you're a good salesperson,
right?
You're obviously doing well.
I just get the sense
that there is a COVID element
that's really escalated
your sales
that aren't gonna be
straight line up
to justify the valuation.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
I appreciate your feedback.
Thanks, Mark.
Tate, the one thing I do know
is sales never lie ‐‐ ever.
You've hit magic.
And how long it's gonna last,
I don't know.
But I want to go along
for the ride.
$900,000
for 3% of the company.
You pay me back $1.50
off every wheel
until I recover
$1.2 million.
Okay.
Would you guys consider
going in on a deal?
With Kevin?
Are you kidding me?
[ Chuckling ] No, no, no.
[ Lori laughs ]
I love ya.
I'm a huge fan.
But I want
Lori and Robert.
Why would I want to partner?
I'll give you
the $900,000.
You'll pay back
$500,000 this year
and $500,000 next year.
Okay.
And I'll do that
for 2.5%.
2.5% or 2%?
2.5%.
Was your original deal 2%?
It was.
[ Laughter ]
Tate, you can absorb
the $1.50 per unit.
Yes, it is a royalty.
It's the first time in 12 years
I've made a royalty deal.
You have learned,
grasshopper.
Greiner:
Why are you afraid?
If you're gonna make the money
you're gonna make ‐‐
I don't have a problem with
that. Neither should you,
because of your cost
of goods.
Let Tate make a decision!
Tate, it's up to you.
What are you gonna do?
Lori, we'd pay you back
$400,000 this year,
$500,000 next year.
You recoup your entire
investment
in the next 18 months ‐‐
no risk.
We don't have to tie it
to $100 million,
and we'll do it at 2%.
♪♪
2.5% and you have a deal.
What happened
to the 2%?
Oh! Either you want the partner
or you don't, Tate.
I mean, seriously.
You have no partners,
Tate.
Yeah,
you have no partners.
Maybe it should be 4%.
[ Laughs ]
You have 97.5% left.
Lori, you got a deal.
Okay!
Whoo‐hoo!
Oh, my gosh!
[ Laughter ]
Cuban: Congrats.
Thanks.
Oh, my gosh!
[ Laughs ]
Aaaah!
Pop, pop, pop,
pop, pop!
What up, what up,
what up? Whooo!
O'Leary: Lori, you make nothing
on your money
till he sells his company ‐‐
maybe.
That's every investment.
When my money leaves,
it comes back with prisoners!
Your money never gets
any prisoners!
It comes back
after 2 years saying,
"Do I still live here
with Lori?
I'm not sure
I ever left this place."
Free money from Lori!
Lori, free money!"
Moving on. Moving on.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪